je vais faire une interview briseur de
ménage annonce que vous êtes toujours
amoureuse de jean michel
oui est-ce qu'il vous regarde toujours
avec la même fougue crise dites moi il
fait le ménage à la maison jean michel
non mais moi non plus hein et la cuisine
non mais moi non plus c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous emmenez week-end
c'était aussi des eaux alors la dernière
fois que vous avez offert des fleurs
voilà je n'aime pas beaucoup les fleurs
et lui non plus il vous ouvre la
portière de la voiture
oui ils vous accompagnez les reports
quand vous partez je sais pas encore
partie des voilà vous avez pas vous
séparer en fait c'est pas s'il viendra
vous chercher quand vous reviendrez donc
il vous fait des petits déjeuners aussi
du déjeuner au lit j'aime pas ça me
regarde les filles dans la rue non
il a une photo de vous dans son
portefeuille ça sent fort salle il
laisse des messages d'amour sur le
miroir de salle de bain du rouge à
lèvres je t'aime johnny depp une motors
portable c'est quoi qui vous énerve le
plus chez lui jan
tu l'a droguée s'est pas positionné ses
chaussettes
on cherche la faille il désordonnée et
les miettes dans le lit mieux mais je
suis très fournis aussi pour nom se
ressemblent beaucoup et ça me dérangera
pas ouais vous l'avez déjà chopé un
travail peu importe au nom desquels vous
avez tourné rajotte et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux